damos paso a las noticias de la economía
con Daniela blandona Daniela saludo
nuevamente para usted Hola Ángela
termino hoy la reunión de dos días de la
reserva Federal qué es lo que se espera
pues mire antes de ir con ese tema le
quiero contar que ella abrió Wall Street
las bolsas están prácticamente mudas a
la espera de lo que vaya a decir la
reserva Federal no se mueve una hoja de
papel en este momento en los mercados
hasta que no se defina qué es lo que va
a hacer el Banco Central de Estados
Unidos y es que las últimas reuniones no
han tenido mucho sorpresa han venido
subiendo las tasas de interés Pero esta
vez hay un condimento adicional que la
hace impredecible e imperdible también y
es la incipiente crisis bancaria ya que
paradójicamente el Banco Central ha sido
considerado al menos indirectamente el
responsable de lo que sucedió con los
bancos colapsados Así que lo que
normalmente sería una reunión de rutina
se perfila más como un acto de
equilibrio en la cuerda floja hay tres
escenarios posibles como lo Alexander
kuroff de Western Virginia University en
el medio de análisis de conversation él
dice el primero es que la Fed suba los
tipos de interés en 25 puntos básicos
Este es el más esperado y tiene sentido
Porque todavía hay que combatir la
inflación
que en Estados Unidos está en un 6%
anual lejos del pico del 9% al que había
llegado el año pasado pero también muy
lejos de la meta del 2% anual que es lo
que tiene la reserva Federal vemos un
segundo escenario y es que la Fed suba
en medio punto porcentual sus tipos de
interés es al que menos le apuestan casi
nadie lo dice lo consideran muy agresivo
para esta coyuntura actual y el tercero
Es que la Fed pause las salsas
consecutivas que viene realizando hace
un par de meses pues era que viene
realizando desde el año pasado era casi
impensable hace un par de meses pero
ahora puede parecer Obvio sin embargo
eso podría enviar una señal equivocada a
los inversionistas de que Si considera
serios todos estos problemas financieros
y terminaría encendiendo esta Mecha de
la crisis financiera bastante no
quisiera estar en los zapatos de Ninguno
de los tomadores de decisiones hoy no
estamos conteniendo la respiración y
esperaremos a la actualización Daniela
pero es que la reserva Federal no es el
único Banco Central que va a tomar
decisiones hoy no en América Latina
también se prepara hoy el Banco Central
de Brasil para decidir qué va a hacer
con los tipos de interés Pero antes
escuchemos las críticas que le hizo el
presidente Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
respecto
es una irresponsabilidad del Banco
Central mantener la tasa de interés en
13,75 por ciento es una
irresponsabilidad
recordemos que en ese mismo sentido
también se han pronunciado otros líderes
de la región como el de Colombia Gustavo
Petro Y es que no en todos los países
bajar la tasa o subir la tasa de interés
mejor implica necesariamente que la
inflación se vaya a desacelerar Y aunque
Brasil ha sido considerado como un
ejemplo relativo de éxito pues su
inflación anual es del 5,6% mucho menos
que sus vecinos el mandatario asegura
que la tasa de interés debería comenzar
a bajar de nuevo en momentos en que ya
no hay exceso de demanda que es lo que
normalmente sube los precios cuando se
junta con un faltante de oferta
Daniela en Perú la gripe había está
afectando la producción de pollo esto
nos lleva a otro tema pero Igualmente
muy importante claro y que tiene que ver
con la inflación justamente porque los
productores avícolas previenen que la
crisis se va a mantener más allá del mes
de abril y ante la escasez se espera que
los precios sigan al alza nuestro
corresponsal en Lima Francisco Zacarías
recorrió algunos comercios y nos amplía
la información en el siguiente reportaje
la gripe aviar obligó a los avicultores
peruanos a eliminar más de 850.000
gallinas en las últimas semanas
alrededor de 15 millones de pollos
dejaron de nacer en un mes para el
productor Avícola y representante de
avisur al exgerí las pérdidas han sido
millonarias con la cantidad que se ha
eliminado han perdido entre 12 y 13
millones de dólares solamente en costo
de inversión sin contar la parte que tú
la producción te la estás no la vas a
tener eso también son un ingreso que no
va a producir para afrontar la
emergencia sanitaria que ha bajado la
producción de pollos en un 25%, el
gobierno anunció la importación de 17
millones de huevos fértiles para ser
criados en las granjas
una de las consecuencias el volumen de
pollo comercializado hoy es 7,2% menor
que el de hace un año Rosa Miranda ama
de casa Comenta que la Alimentación en
su hogar ha cambiado ya no es igual No
ya ya no Uno no puede ya dar las
porciones como dabas No ya ya es menos
ya las porciones el kilo de pollo en los
mercados de Lima y su área metropolitana
promedia los 3,37 dólares 35% más caro
que un año atrás la inflación en Perú
fue del 9% anual en febrero con los
alimentos subiendo el doble impulsados
por el precio del ave
los restaurantes que venden pollo a la
brasa típica comida de los peruanos
también notan el sobrecosto y con eso
cómo hacemos la clientela va a llover te
va a bajar porque ya el precio no es muy
accesible Y lamentablemente Tenemos que
pasar esta situación afrontarlo porque
no sabemos qué va a pasar pues porque si
se siguen una cosa van a quebrar ese es
el problema
los peruanos esperan que las autoridades
avancen con la vacunación de pollos y
solucionen la escasez y el alza del
precio pero los agricultores advierten
que el proceso será lento
un tema que ha sido motivo de análisis
de directo a América esta mañana en
Colombia finalmente autorizaron la
integración de dos aerolíneas pero con
condiciones Claro que sí y antes de
decírselo si quiero rescatar algo y es
que la democratización de los viajes
prácticamente está llegando a su fin y
las personas con menos recursos pues no
van a poder viajar en avión por los
precios altos pues después de muchos
reparos quejas de las otras empresas y
de meses de análisis la aeronáutica
civil de Colombia finalmente bendijo el
matrimonio entre la principal aerolínea
del país Avianca y su mayor rival de
bajo costo viva era Esta última afronta
una crisis financiera grave que la llevó
a suspender sus vuelos nacionales e
internacionales el pasado 27 de febrero
dejando a miles de personas varadas en
los aeropuertos el principal reparo del
regulador era que esta integración
podría generar una indebida restricción
de la Competencia por eso Entonces
condicionó este negocio al cumplimiento
de varias cosas por un lado que les
respondan a los pasajeros de viva air
todos los vuelos cancelados y las
afectaciones que tuvieron también exigen
la devolución de los llamados slots que
impliquen la concentración en franjas de
alto uso los slots son las asignaciones
de horarios y frecuencias que tienen las
aerolíneas en los aeropuertos otra de
las condiciones es mantener el esquema
low cost de viva Air y devolver las
frecuencias en la ruta Bogotá Buenos
Aires que es una de las más impactadas
finalmente pidió conservar el límite de
tarifas en rutas en donde quede con el
100% de la operación este último punto
es el que yo veo un poquito difícil
Daniela y usted hablaba de las
afectaciones que podrían darse en países
como Colombia que son pues es nuestro
país de residencia Pero esto que está
sucediendo este fenómeno de las
aerolíneas de bajo costo pues está
dándose a nivel mundial no en todas
partes cada vez es más difícil sostener
este negocio y más aún después de la
pandemia Así que digamos que este
problema de la democratización de los
viajes pues al final nos afecta a todos
no nos afecta a todos Sí porque al final
se Están volviendo todas las aerolíneas
de bajo costo se Están volviendo casi
que de alto costo
y ni hablemos de los precios vamos con
su cifra del día rápidamente días coma
cuatro por ciento fue la inflación
interanual de Reino Unido en febrero Es
la primera vez que se acelera en tres
meses después de un pico del 11,1% en
octubre venía reduciéndose
bastante pero en este lapso nunca estuvo
por debajo del doble dígito que lo tiene
liderando el alza de precios entre sus
vecinos europeos que están muy por
debajo de ese 9 10% que tiene Reino
Unido pues Daniela gracias a usted nos
vemos mañana con las noticias así